[Music]  are you ready to begin  you felt it the minute you held her in  your arms she's the same as you isn't  she  she doesn't know who or what she is yet  [Music]  this  [Music]  June is a very special girl she needs us  she's shift like us  she's a mother  [Music]  tell me it's gonna be okay  do you think I'm a monster it all  monstah tuned Jewish not like the other  women  she's everything you're looking for she  and doctor  such a rare thing  I know you're frightened to do so much  you are she's got the key well it's not  a gift  it's a curse I don't want good to be  like me just close your eyes I know you  better than anyone and if you save at  this point you will know I know it  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]